bauser muss ganz viel fress und kriegt
jetzt auch was zu fressen und jung die
lieben sich die macht und ohnmacht
direkt von der ganzen familie
nudeln nudeln
wir spielen hier jetzt exit hero das ist
ok mirror server und ich kann mich schon
wieder nicht einloggen es geht immer das
erst einmal nicht deswegen das mache ich
mittlerweile schon mal vor den aufnahmen
war bei mir ist das immer höchst
professionell
ich bin mitten im niemandsland hatte
kannst du kurz schlafen gehen
scheiße da kann ich aber dann muss ich
komme ins haus gehen
bist du nicht ausgezogen ich bin
ausgezogen aber ich habe keinen score
karte steht auch ein eigentor ein moment
wo ich bin alt geworden achja konkretes
übrigens gebäude ist bei uns in der
stadt als auch ihrer world schon gemerkt
stimmt wir sind ja nicht in einer stadt
alter ja gut dann ist es halt die erste
anti ich habe schon mal mitkommen
aufgenommen ist es halt so die zweite
over statt aufnahme aber das eigentlich
auch dann fällig oma opa wie willst denn
sonst ausdrücken kann aber auf jeden
fall klingt oberstadt richtig bin
behindert altstadt es richtig geil wird
sich richtig für fue touristikern ja
schreiben kommentare herr staeck
oberstadt hashtag auf jeden fall den
welthandel hat jetzt auch instagram
deswegen das hashtag wo was passiert
jetzt eine locker abgebaut und dann
haben sie sich da wieder hin
teleportiert scheiße
nein ich glaube minecraft will einfach
nicht dass du diese blöcke a post ab das
war kein leck junge das ist so heftig
also ich bin ja jetzt mal gestorben
logge dich niemand lande die ich ich
finde hier sachen die ich noch nie in
meinem leben zuvor gesehen habe zum
beispiel sondern seine rote sandstein
ebene oder ich finde einfach an jeder
zweiten ecke sind einfach diamanten bei
diesen roten sandstein ebenen sind immer
ganz viele pavillons und außer man will
los kann man sich eine rüstung morgen
ehrlich ich bin doch schon mal vorbei
gelaufen ich habe jetzt an die ka news
wieder uns drin
ich habe jetzt einfach die ganzen
diamanten die überall so rumgammeln aber
das sind echt immens viele ich glaube
ich ein wort das so oft sagt alter
immens wir nehmen seiten wir nehmen seit
ein zweieinhalb minuten auf cobo hältst
hier welche werte ich oft sei
walter ich habe schon öfter mal mit ihr
geredet oder mal ein video gesehen du
seinen eltern schnauze nicht okay dann
was kann ich denn außer dem entsagen
gesamten synonym ja keine ahnung in dem
zusammenhang in dem du es benutzt gibt
es acht millionen verschiedene wort oder
für halte da ist immens viel da ist
extrem viel stärkere stilistisches
gutschreiben in mein haus ist festlich
oder ich verstehe es echt nicht junge
ich ich ich ich glaube ich werde nie
nach hause finden weil ich an jeder
zweiten ecke diamanten finden die immer
den drang hat die abzubauen
außer diesen ganz weit oben auf dem berg
aber da bin ich gerade auch noch mal
hoch gelaufen verstehen muss viel
passiert im alter ich glaub ich hole mir
knochen und um den hund nur noch kunden
reifen oder habe ich sollte man
hinzufügen
dieser habe ich endlich zeit betten
junge so welcher von euch ist dann wenn
zutraulich aus du nachher ist mir viel
zu jolo alter der läuft einfach vom berg
herum kommt als genommen hund
weggelaufen und man hat mich genommen er
will mehr
das ist gar ich kann ja sogar noch
weiter das ist das falsche wort
ja sag mir mal was planst du denn so
otto ist das gotteshaus dank hopps
natürlich ausgezogen habe meine wohnung
so in berg rhein gebaut und jetzt wenn
ich komme nicht aus versehen im rhein
gestoßen
ja ich will eigentlich nach hause habe
ich traue mich eben nicht erst richtig
hätte nein ich brauche ich will den hund
holen einfach so weil ich hab mal ich
will jetzt machen dass ich jeden sonntag
mit meinem hund um die häuser ziehen und
dann immer so sage was ich da so
verändert hat und den hund wollte ich
behandeln weil ich bin richtig cooler
name für rund okay okay aber ich brauche
halt knochen und ich hab halt keine
knochen weil ich so klug von mir den
ganzen knoch und da sind knochen haben
riesige knochen klingel gebaut es denn
eine knochen klingen ist es besser als
seine diamond award ich glaube nicht
nein ich glaube dies ist genau so stark
wie ein diamant wird aber das hat
irgendein fähigkeit das soll cool und
die kennst du nicht
das ist gut für das groß und stark aus
du wirst du behindert ist das ist das
ein geiler und komm bitte ja ja ihr
könnt mir browser cache und bauteile
noch die so nahm zettel und in echt zu
alter stimmt ich kann mir einen tag
machen wie geht das
browser guard mit die spieler kommen
jetzt mit so browser kommt jetzt mit ja
leute ich hab runde und er folgt wir
sogar herzchen übersicht alter ich bin
so stolz ich bin so stolz auf bause
ehemals die nächste frage
scheiße der wird nie überleben bis zu
mir nach hause der wird einfach in
worunter vor allem die frage ist ob du
ist überhaupt überleben wie es alter du
bist erst mal ganz ruhig
wieso ich guck dich mal ein alter wie
oft bist du schon gestorben
dreimal in vier folgen oder einmal wegen
hunger das andere mal weil ich im
braunen bären angegriffen habe ja das
ist schon schön blöd dass der das war
richtig toll oh das war richtig geil den
anzugreifen
da ich mich richtig stark gefühlt sms
verschickt hat und jetzt bin ich auf dem
weg nach hause sind auch nur noch 4000
blöcke obwohl eigentlich sinn 4000
blöcke ja gar nicht so viel wenn man
sich das mal überlegt scheiße dass ein
pferd
wenn du schon bist du schon als ich sind
halb so halb so weit wie die städte
auseinander sind die sind schon recht
weit auseinander
14.000 plakat hatte außerdem ist von
10.000 nicht 4000 junge ein bisschen
unzufrieden kann man sich eigentlich
diese blauen gräser mitnehmen wo diese
komischen herzchen rauskommen ich weiß
nicht was du meinst mit blauen gläsern
aus dem herzchen rauskommt bis ich
dachte tat richtig ahnung jetzt ein
richtig tolles schwert eine frage war ob
ich ihn einfach dann fahre ich einfach
tadel dürfte alter alte alte alter alter
alter ich finde ich bin den treibsand
ich bin 13
auch sagt mich dass du wieder stil ich
bin draußen
alles gut
da frage ich ihn einfach woher diese
tollen schwerter her hat und ob er die
ahnung hat ja ich hab bei wirklich bei
google einfach exit weapon eingegeben
oder kam das als erstes ja das hat
irgendwann effekt weiß zwar nicht welche
aber ich hab es ja es ist echt wie
sollen behinderte arme der eu
hauptstraße ecke liegt und sich nicht
sehr helfen weiß und ist deswegen
behindert also jetzt geht es wieder los
das hast du gegen nicht das ist mal
wieder so ich mache so richtig verplante
scheiße ich mache mir blöcke weg und
setzt sie dann wieder hin
ich weiß nicht ob ich links oder rechts
laufen rechts durch die schlucht oder
links oder bergrechts immer rechts vor
links regel extrem denke ich noch mal
zurück ist muss aber nicht wasser
schwimmen was du mir zumute ist wieder
eine ace gold eigentlich wertvoll in
diesem spiel
ich weiß es nicht danke ich habe einfach
keine ahnung von nichts ahnung was
willst du von mir meinte mal das gold
irgendwie wertvoll sei aber ich habe so
viel gold ist glaubt leben gar nicht
also ich habe mich viel gold aber ich
finde einfach so viel gehört und denke
weil ich so viel finde bei euch einiges
ab und es dann ja eh voll für gibt wofür
gibt ich habe gar nicht so viel ich am 7
ich behindert ich hab noch des todes
fiel einfach nur neun gold ich glaube
ich dass behindert ist okay dass ein
warzenschwein dass ein warzenschwein
greifen die von so an oder soll ich den
angreifen
ich weiß dass nicht alte ich kenne das
spiel auch nicht ok ich muss einfach
nach anders an
ich versuche jetzt mit einfachen grund
zu holen den browser reicht eigentlich
komme ich doch browser wende ein kleines
mädel hier kriegt seine freunde arosa
und composer schläppi chaplet alter
browser ist und ist ein richtig frech
teleportiert sich immer und er lässt
sich das wasser schwimmen geht los ich
kann jetzt nicht auseinanderhalten jetzt
auseinander junge tschechien hatte der
browser muss ganz viel fressen keep it
kriegt jetzt auch was zu fressen
die lieben sich erholt sich auch direkt
einen ganzen familie alles etwas einfach
jetzt dass die auf baby hunde machen
können warnt petra geburt junge als bin
ich müssen neidisch ich kann dir die
kleinen baby hund abgeben
wir werden uns die wir in diesem vierten
spiel doch irgendwann mein krieges für
euch komme ich da mit meinem kleinen
hund geschenkt streaming
also baut das echt ein frecher
teleportiert sich immer seine familie
kommt dann so halb notgedrungen
hinterher
ich sitze ich eigentlich doppelt hier
meinen weg wieder ganz viel schweine sie
morgen also wenn ihr sehen wollt wie
tadel sein haus baut dann könnt ihr
vorbei drücken
es ist aber echt spannend man guckt
einfach nicht dann könnt ihr noch luca
gucken wie niedlich der hund ist aber
ihr könnt auch einfach warten bis immer
ein krieg mit den erwarteten alter mein
baby wolf hat nur noch 8 von 20 leben
ach ich hab dem einfach ganz viel
fleisch mund gestopft hat geht sie
wieder gut machen in sachen dungeon
reingehen
das ist ein ganz einfach nicht noch mal
sterben 1 handel das ist kein dungeon
das ist einfach nur ein mammutbaum ja
das ist bestimmt auch visionen werden
wer weiß was da drin ist ja weil jeder
denkt ich rein aber die s 2
der ist direkt daneben steht einfach so
ein kleiner baum und der kleine baum ist
einfach mal das sind zwei riesen bäume
was sind eigentlich da die das kennst du
aber diese gelben pelikan vögel oder der
pelikan für den meister chocobos alter
jakobus dass toni final fantasy gespielt
nein habe ich nicht
als ich gehört hat das ist die hier gibt
junge ich bin vor freude ausgerastet
ehrlich ich hab ja eine kette die loni
gespielt schreibt eure kommentare ob ihr
final fantasy x gespielt habe final
fantasy 7 alter ich habe das nie
gespielt aber in sieben hatten die ihren
großen auftritt waren die super cool tut
mir das sind halt so reittiere die man
ziehen konnte und dann gleitet man ja
dass man die 10 konnte das weiß ich auch
aber wie geht das mit diesel oder so ist
so ein komisches gratis eilig hat gesagt
wer aber du brauchst dann halt auch noch
im sattel
ich hab keinen sattel scheiße das aber
so ein komisches medium wieder
also ich sehe hier echt dinge die ich
noch nie in meinem leben zuvor gesehen
habe
hast du davor schon mal hexe gespielt ja
hab ich sogar aber ich treffe trotzdem
hier so viele neue sachen weil wir
spielen ja auch mit seinem update
beispiel mit mit einer älteren version
die hexe von einem halben jahr mal
engagiert ok kannst du dich vielleicht
schlafen legen
was kann ich tun battery ist noch ok hat
muss eben ein schlafplatz bin ich jetzt
meine hunde den ich letzthin einfach
eine fackel damit ihr keine angst haben
okay ist alles gut jetzt mein ich habe
ein tollen ausblick auf 4 fette eisbären
aber naja
wie lange schon auf zwölf minuten wir
noch richtig viel zeit richtig viel
pharma verflogen
ich muss nur noch 3000 blogger jetzt auf
mittlerweile bücher gar nicht so viel
mehr warum wird eigentlich oh mein gott
pinguine
ach du scheiße wieder denn das ist schon
so erfahrung macht pinguine und
einhörner links einer rechts pinguin
ethanol an rechne habe ich noch nicht
gesehen sind einfach einhörner gehört
aber slava ich nicht 100 online also was
ist denn mit dir los bist du für ein
kaputtes wesen mit einhörnern wie komme
ich auf ein höherer wie ich zu behindert
den namen grad zu wissen wie heißt aber
diese tierchen mit dem horn
die tun nix die heißen eisbären haben
könne hören ein schatten über diese
tiere mit dem mit dem horn obendrauf
da gibt es einige themen
warum fällt jetzt auch spontan gar kein
name ein nashorn ist ein pokemon ja die
ganze zeit fakten nicht behindert sorry
es tut mir leid ich weißt du was ich mir
mit einer mit einer goldenen denn mit
einer feder und wenn ich gewinne gold
umkreise was sie daraus machen kann nur
gold fehlt aber was bringt die st
soweit ich weiß dass meine ja deswegen
das habe ich mich auch schon gefragt und
ich konnte ich habe das meinen die
zuschauer gefragt aber ich konnte noch
nicht wieder eine kommentare gucken weil
es direkt weiter mit ihr aufkommen
ja ich hätte auch drei verschiedene
seerose und denke mannschaft bis zur
nächsten fall immer wieder runter ins
wasser
sie sind meine täuschen der moment in
meinem leben die hunde porten sich
einfach diese frechen wollte ich würde
sie auch runde ich bin richtig neidisch
geworden
du musst dir und dann aber auch einen
namen geben und dann wir machen dann
dieses einen pakt dass wenn wir uns dann
treffen wenn du hunger hast und ich ab
hunde dann treffen wir uns im krieg
und dann ich habe villiger dorf gefunden
und dann und da nicht haben will
bernie und dann machen wir die auf jeden
fall so dass wir die paar euro ja alter
jedes mal wirklich ja das wird richtig
sexy jetzt wirklich titel ohne witz ja
ich meine es ernst
nein jetzt wirklich ehrlich also ohne
witz ganz ehrlich qualcomm mit gar
keinen witz dabei ja gar kein witz auch
kein joggen darf auch nicht witzig du
bist auch nicht wenn er dabei wäre wird
ist einfach kacke dann halt ne ja genau
einfach kacke ich hatte auch diese
möchtegern pilze möchtegern rotwild der
denkt zu essen rotwild aber jetzt
einfach so ein breiter pilz und die kann
man einfach nicht in die gänge packen
ich habe letztens so eine blume gesehen
das war dem singleplayer dadurch nämlich
kurz ein bisschen crafting schritt
ausprobiert damit ich nicht in der folge
acht jahre dafür braucht die diebe haben
einfach geleuchtet so blumen die waren
wie so eine lampe die konten weiß ich es
gibt ja die blauen blumen leuchten und
zwar wenn du die kaputt schlägt bekommst
du so ein leben und so
ich weiß nicht ob wir das selbe meinten
doch machen wir hier schon wieder sein
schwarzer berg in diesem schwarzen bären
die suche nur stress die schwarzen
jungen ihm auf jeden fall war das
mainufer die konnte man abbauen und wenn
man die aufgestellt hat dann kam einfach
nicht raus oder kannten wir das doch
nicht das was wir meinen dass ich meine
was tut man was wir beide mein mann
weißt du was ich hab echt mittlerweile
so das gefühl dass ich in die komplett
falsche richtung laufe ich muss auf
jeden fall die ganz linke koordinaten
muss 4000 sein dafür sind jetzt noch
2000 blöcke eigentlich ist das wirklich
gar nicht so weit ich habe jetzt in
einer folge 2000 flocke geschafft in 15
minuten und ich bin einfach boa die
ganze schwarzenberg und ich bin einfach
noch an jeder zweiten stelle stehen
geblieben habe mir noch pietsch browser
und den kleinen geholt schreibt wenn
meine kommentare namen für den kleinen
wie könnte ich in den kleinen nennen
also auf jeden fall auch ein cooler name
ist muss jetzt auch nicht aus mario sein
es sollte jetzt nicht sowas sein wie
schnupfen oder flug- oder england hatte
oder so dass der katla ja stimmt schon
also das ist schon nicht also schon hat
grenze hätte ich schon echt schrecklich
diese hunde sind echt so frech ich
kratze den berg runter und brecht meine
beine und die teleportiert sich einfach
ihre kranken ist ein eigenartiger sofort
was heißt dagegen eine sprache hat
nichts mit aussprache zu tun kann
deutsch verstanden kraxeln ist ein
immens geiles wort demand immens ist
voll schön ich mag das
danke was ist eigentlich mit tim und
steht das sind doch die betten von tim
und stege oder schreibt dass man die
kommentare
dass die die schlafen einfach draußen
und da unter den werten ist einfach nur
dreck einfach dreck wirklich minecraft
dreck so wie haben sie ihr haus und dann
geht ein kleiner weg raus und so ein
umzäuntes stück dreck und das stehen die
wette vielleicht mögen die schwarz ich
ja vor allem schlafen wieder zusammen
die sich stehen
diese melo paris diesen sogar die kann
man richtig schnell essen die highlands
war ein halbes leben aber die kann man
so schnell die reifen
das ärgert mich immer richtig an mich
ich brauche jetzt noch nur noch 1500
blogger sind schon wieder bei 18 halb
minuten regeln und ich zwar dass wir
nicht mehr so lange machen da hinten ist
schon wieder so ein scheiß posthum ich
will mich denn eigentlich gar nicht mehr
und ich will erst mal nach hause kommen
besser aufstellen dann mache ich machten
dann gehen alle dämme rein was sie auch
immer wollte und sterbt dann
wahrscheinlich wieder tausendfach aber
da ist auch schon vollauf gestorben der
zocker drei firma gestorben das kann
sein ja
es kann nicht so sicher wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so blöd von der weiter an
macht
er vertrat auch ich habe außerdem komme
eisen geklaut das gibt ihm gleichzeitig
dem piratenschiff
ich sehne richtig hab noch nie so fett
ist das bett ist auch einmal männlich
gewonnen
degerloch
ok dann mache ich in der nächsten folge
weiter das kann doch nicht sein wie fett
ist dass ich meine ich bin ja im
singleplayer schon manchmal um geflogen
da waren zwei schiffe die waren immer so
ein paar bröckchen lang 20 blogger aber
das ist einfach mal 1000 blöcke langen
und millionen blogger hoch titanic motto
junge wer hier in eisbergen
ich bin doch noch immer als bio das sind
irgendwelche anzeichen glaube ich ja es
wird weil die man sterben der jec heißt
19 er wird euch gehen noch mal kurz an
die öfen alter wir sind gleich über 20
minuten hatte paolo
ja ich gehe jetzt eben noch schnell zu
kommen und gibt ihm das eisen was ich
noch von ihm habe ich auch das hinaus
was geklaut das ist ein guter grund
dafür dass wir jetzt einfach länger
machen
nein ich gehe jetzt nach hause können
wir ausmachen leute ich sage schon mal
guckt mal bei luca vorbei wie schön so
einen kleinen hunde sind und schreibt
auf jeden fall könnte hat den namen
schreiben wie wir kleine hunde nennen
sollen wo ist er eigentlich der weg doch
das hier wird schon irgendwo sein
ja ich werde jetzt schon mal runter vom
server bevor wir noch viel zu lang hier
sind ja okay dann würde ich sagen morgen
direkt wir sind ja nicht gestorben
ausnahmsweise ist luca nicht gestorben
du bist jetzt ganz ruhig ich habe mich
so angestrengt
ja so auch super gemacht danke schön und
stolz auf dich